avant la guerre l'ukraine était
considérée comme le grenier à blé de
l'europe un peu aussi celui de la
planète car elle produisait environ 15%
de la consommation mondiale mais
aujourd'hui le pays ne peut plus se
targuer du même statut beaucoup de
chansons me n'est impossible dans ces
conditions d'accès des ro culture les
démineurs ont inspecté la zone parce que
les conducteurs de tracteurs ne peuvent
pas faire leur travail ils nous disent
nous n'irons pas dans les champs tant
que vous n'aurez pas récupéré les mines
et les bombes il fallait donc les
ramasser deschamps qui manque aussi
désespérément de main d'oeuvre ceux qui
travaillaient ici étaient des hommes la
plupart sont partis au front pour
combattre l'envahisseur russe beaucoup
ne reviendront pas synonyme de futures
récoltes perdues
d'autant que 80% des terres agricoles
ukrainienne serait toujours sous
contrôle de kiev certains agriculteurs
travaillent d'arrache-pied mais le
problème c'est l'exportation ou masse
comme de la récolte de l'an dernier nous
avons encore environ 20 millions de
tonnes de céréales en ukraine
aujourd'hui et d'autres produits
agricoles que nous n'avons pas réussi à
expédier tous ces obstacles font
aujourd'hui craindre une crise
alimentaire mondiale car certains pays
et institutions dépendent presque
exclusivement de l'ukraine c'est
notamment le cas du programme
alimentaire mondial de l'onu qui se
fournit à 40% blé ukrainien humble et
ensuite redistribués à des personnes
menacées par la famine en éthiopie au
yémen ou en afghanistan